okay push the red button
push it again there we go
okay testing okay I think everything
everything is working okay um so we're
here in Norway and I've got a team of
Norwegian poi experts to help me show
you how air wraps work Harold's going to
be my what I call my boy slow-mo
demonstrator you're just gonna hold the
handles like this he's not gonna move so
in an air wrap it's done in split time
wall plans
so the ploy you're flying this way now
from actually if you go up high for a
sec the point need to start either what
I call convex or concave so the player
either pointing out a little bit or
pointing in a little bit normally people
begin an arrow pointing out so come back
down low
so what's important to understand is see
how the poi create a line from the
tethers to the not the point either be
in front of that line or they can be
behind that line and when they go from
one to the other is how an air wrap
works so for instance they're gonna
collide like that if they were to both
go behind the line together they're just
gonna stay tangled air wraps don't work
that way
every wraps work when one of the play
leads so the air up either needs to
swing under that line or you can even
make it swing over that line which is
much weirder and harder so almost
everybody all the times that's a swing
under and we'll show you this from the
top in a moment so if they're going
along watch if the orange poi see how
it's inside if it then stays inside
while the green also is inside they come
undone that's when an air wrap works the
things that go wrong if they both go
inside at the same time it tangles if
the orange leads in and then goes back
out you have that like a hyper loop or
an orbital and air wrap only works when
if you're starting Connie vex if the poi
coming down is the first one inside see
this one's still outside this one's
inside and then they're both inside they
come undone so we'll show that from
above a little bit if you step here and
turn around yeah and they're gonna hold
it way out here so angle that's it so
watch they they collide if the orange is
the first one inside followed by the
green one they come I'm done you can
also start the whole thing from the
inside they could collide on the inside
orange leads out followed by the green
they come undone orange leads in they
come undone orange it's the first one
out now again if they try to go out
together it doesn't work if they start
on the outside if they go in at the same
time they just get tangled so one of the
first exercises you can do is you take
your poi and you just
get them hanging like that and you just
practiced a feeling of that anything
swing in swing in swing in and it's just
pulling with the fingers and an opening
of the elbows you could also try to go
over the top but that's much harder if
you just do this a bunch they get some
muscle memory of teaching the ploy to
swing in through the bottom that muscle
memory is what happens when the poi
collide if you just do that swing motion
the play will swing in and come undone
so it's a few things you can practice
one thing is your planes need to be
really straight you can go from high up
again
you need control where you can decide if
they're angled a little bit out or a
little bit in if you don't have that
control to make them angle away angle
towards angle away
I call it saloon doors if you can't do
that you'll have a lot of trouble you
might learn it but it'll it'll be clunky
I really recommend the first thing you
should do is learn this control when
you've got that control most people
begin an air wrap when the poi are
angled out and when they collide you
expect words once you can do it from
convex to concave look how my place
finish concave I can also go from
concave to convex I don't practice
concave to convex very much so I often
flub that one up we will return shortly
with more ideas for learning air wraps
because it's raining audio going on
alright alright so to finish where we
were there's a few skills that are
pretty important one of them is eyes are
showing being able to comfortably go
from convex to concave plants the other
thing and I've seen people really
struggle with this is getting used to
the poem coming into this space which we
can call a water mill water mill is
coming from the front of your arms
through the back of your arms here and
I've watched people say oh yeah but they
can't do it so you really need to learn
to come here and probably you might have
to take one poi start from swinging it's
a weird feeling for some people at first
maybe swinging the poi in between your
arms and your body
I see people say oh yeah you mean like
this and that's only going behind one
arm or they go like this
that's only behind the other arm you
need to pass behind both arms the next
thing if you keep from above
I'm going to do left boy coming down
it's gonna connect with my right finger
and it's going to flip to the inside so
watch that a few times hopefully we'll
slow that down from outside to inside
now what tends to go wrong is things
like this where it came behind this arm
and then in front of the other arm you
want to pass it from in front to behind
both arms outside the inside it also go
on the other one up up up up up up so
once you can do that with your hand
pulling it into the inside do the same
thing with your poi this is a classic
move where people make it difficult by
trying to do too much it works but you
can even close your eyes and just as a
hit if you close your eyes and don't do
anything that's often where it will work
85% of the time when I watch somebody
learning this for the first time they go
and they make I'm exaggerating but they
make a lot of movement and it almost
always gets in the way if you can
convince your arms to do almost nothing
that's more likely to make it succeed I
just make space and I let the POIs Wing
in on their own once you've got a
clockwise you can learn it
counterclockwise Boop
once you've got it from convex to
concave you can try concave to convex if
you've got all the swing unders you can
try a swing over it's so much harder on
a swing over the poi going up has to be
the one that leads over the top like
that
now so this is this is Norway by the way
these these the people we have here this
is Peter one of the main organizers
organizers of camp flow of stranded
Harold he's been taking me around Norway
the amazing cameraman is Richard you can
wave juice and yeah we're going around
making play videos in fjords and thanks
for watching
[Music]
you